[MUSIC PLAYING]
MICHAEL HELMICK: Hi, everyone.
Welcome.
My name is Mike Helmick.
I'm a software engineer working
on serverless for Google Cloud
Platform.
STEREN GIANNINI: Hi, I'm Steren
Giannini, a product manager
on the serverless team.
Welcome to Run Containers
on GCP's Serverless
Infrastructure.
Well, you all know what
we are talking about here.
We are talking about Cloud Run,
a product that we are really
excited to launch and that
we announced yesterday,
that allows you
to run containers
on all serverless
infrastructure.
So first, what is serverless?
This is how we define
serverless at Google Cloud.
The three characteristics
are that you do not
manage the infrastructure,
you have a managed security,
and you only pay for usage.
If you take those three
characteristics, you can think,
that doesn't only apply
to compute products.
And indeed, all
of those products
are, if we apply those
characteristics, by definition,
serverless.
For example, if you
want to install data,
Firestore is an ideal
serverless database.
If you want to do Cron
job, well, Cloud Scheduler
is an ideal way
to not worry about
where your Crons are running
in a fully-managed environment.
And more precisely, we have
three serverless products,
including Cloud Run.
So we are introducing
Cloud Run that
allows you to bring
serverless to containers.
So, Mike, why don't
you show us how easy
it is to deploy a
container to Cloud Run.
Let's switch to the demo.
MICHAEL HELMICK: So let's
switch over to the demo.
We've shown this
demo several times
in several different sessions.
So you may have seen it already.
We're just going to
show you how quick it
is to get a pre-built container
up and running in Cloud Run.
So here I am in the Cloud
Run UI, in the Cloud console.
So we're going to
hit Create Service.
We've provided you an
example container right here.
This is our official
Hello World container.
It will pre-populate
the service name
based on the container name.
You're free to change
that if you like.
It'll give you a
dropdown for locations.
I promise, that list is
going to get longer soon.
And then I'm going to
click Allow Unauthenticated
Invocations.
So by default, services
in Cloud Run are private.
We'll talk more about what that
actually means in a minute,
but I want to put this
container on the internet.
I'm going to go
ahead and hit Create.
It flips over to
the service display.
I see creating service.
So there's a couple of
cycles to go through here.
It's going to say,
deploying revision,
performing health check.
So after we pull your
container into our system,
we actually start it up.
It's already done.
We start it up.
Make sure that it can start.
We return an error if it can't.
And then we give you an URL.
So right there, I
have an HTTPS URL.
I can click over,
and that container
is serving in less
than 10 seconds.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
I'll switch back
over to the slides.
We'll tell you about
how this works.
STEREN GIANNINI: So you
might [INAUDIBLE] that's
a great piece of technology,
but why would I use Cloud Run?
So let's go a little bit
more into the use cases.
So we can split them
into two main categories.
Always, you can run HTTP
request-driven workloads.
So some of them, you will be
using them for public-facing
services--
anything that is exposed
to the internet that
is serving things
over the internet,
for example, a website, or
exposing an API endpoint,
backend for your mobile app,
or just a simple web hook
for when you're receiving web
hook from GitHub or a chat bot,
for example.
But you can also use Cloud
Run if you are breaking out
the monolith of your
application and are
using private microservices.
In that case, those services
are not accessible by anybody
on the internet.
They are within your
service, your application.
And all of those microservices
will be indefinitely scalable.
So if one of them is not in use,
it will just not be scaled up.
And it will be scaled
up when needed.
You can do direct
microservice to microservice,
but also do asynchronous
task execution.
And here, we've seen
many of our alpha testers
using Cloud Run to do
data transformation, image
processing, video processing,
document processing, as you
might have seen in
some other sessions.
And all of this, you can do as
asynchronous task execution,
where the task is going to
trigger the Cloud Run service.
So as one of our
alpha testers says,
what is great about Cloud Run
is that because it accepts
any stateless
container, it allows
you to use your own custom tool
chains, both in terms of tool
chain to manipulate containers,
to build them, but also,
your tool chains
inside the container.
In that case, Thomas
from Airbus is
using Cloud Run to
run his own custom
binary in a serverless way
to do some image processing.
But the binary is not
something that you usually
can put in a
serverless environment.
Except now, with
Cloud Run, because you
can give any
stateless container,
you can actually
give any software
to run on a serverless
environment.
So in that session, we
are going to deep dive
into Cloud Run, in particular,
into the fully-managed version
of Cloud Run.
So we are going to go around
the many characteristics
of the product, so that you
have a very good understanding
of it.
All right, let's go.
The first-- containers,
containers and serverless,
two things that we don't
really think go well together.
That reminds me--
peanut butter and jelly.
Who would have imagined that
mixing peanut butter and jelly
would be so delicious?
Well, it's the same.
You mix the
serverless principles
with the flexibility
of containers,
and you get something
really powerful.
And this is what Cloud Run does.
So containers-- let's
keep going a little bit.
First, they will allow
you to use any programming
language you want.
You are not interested
anymore about which language
you can use, because the
cloud provider decided to only
support those languages.
No, this time, you use
your custom languages.
We are going to do a demo with
Elixir, which is not something
that you've probably seen a lot
on a serverless environment.
I personally run shell
scripts on the Cloud Run.
Along with your
favorite language,
you can bring any
language package,
but also, any OS package.
So if you have a package from
Ubuntu you want to install,
you can do so.
Along with these, you can
bring your own custom binaries
as long as they are compiled
for the right system.
But that's really
something very powerful.
You don't even need to
go from source anymore.
If you have a binary
that does something,
put it into the container.
And as we all know, containers
have a very large ecosystem
around them.
In particular, they are
very large ecosystems
of base images, some
of them maintained
by the official
language maintainers.
And all of this is available
on Docker Hub, for example.
And lastly, we have to
acknowledge that containers
have become an industry
standard, an industry
standard to package software,
to distribute software,
to test software, and
even to deploy software.
It's, in my opinion, much
better than a zip file.
So, Mike is going to
talk to you about what
your containers needs to
meet to run on Cloud Run.
MICHAEL HELMICK: Thank you.
So we have what we call the
container runtime contract.
The container runtime
contract that we
use in Cloud Run
and Cloud Run on GKE
is the Knative container
runtime contract.
So this is an open
spec that we published.
It defines just a
few things that you
need to do inside
your container for us
to be able to
automatically scale it.
So the first one is that we're
focused on stateless workloads.
What this means to you as
an application developer
is that you should
not rely on any given
instance of your
application living for more
than one request.
Now in practice,
on Cloud Run, we
do reuse an instance
of your container,
and we'll send multiple
requests to it.
But we'll also scale them
up and down as needed.
So we're not a great
use case for, say,
running a mem cache
inside of your container.
You can't guarantee it's
going to stay there.
With that, we require that
you listen on a specific port.
We pass in an environment
variable called port.
In practice, it's
usually 80/80, but you
should be prepared for that
to change at any given time.
That's part of the contract.
And we only support
HTTP 1.0, currently--
1.1.
We don't support
any streaming RPCs.
There's some scaling issues
with persistent connections
that I'll be happy to talk about
more in depth after the talk.
And then instances
of your container
are only running when
handling the user requests.
This is how we're able to
offer the scale that we
do on Cloud Run.
So between servicing
user requests,
we actually throttle your
CPU down to near zero,
so that you're not being billed.
Your container is
actually not running.
So with that, I'm going
to show you some code.
I'm going to show you
a demo that I've built.
So let's switch over
to the demo machine.
I'll show that
URL several times,
so you can get the
source, if you like.
So Steren mentioned
this earlier.
I've written this demo
entirely in Elixir.
Elixir is a dynamic language
that runs on the Erlang VM.
I decided I'd throw some
random things at Cloud Run
and see how we do.
I also happen to really
like functional languages.
So what I've written
here is a chat bot.
It works with Google
Hangouts Chat.
So if you have a G
Suite domain, this
is something you
could easily do.
It has a nice chat interface.
And of course, we're using
the power of Cloud Run
to generate memes,
because why not?
So create.
I just have a simple
command Create.
It's going to go create a meme.
This is actually two different
microservices running out
on Cloud Run--
one to do the chat
bot interface,
one to generate the images.
It responds fairly quickly.
But let's say here
that what I want to do
is, I want to--
this is right now
a direct chat with the chat.
But let's say I want
to put this in rooms,
because of course, memes are
more fun if we're sharing them
with other people.
So I want this to, when
it responds with the meme,
to put the author,
attribute this
to the author of the
person who wrote it.
So let's switch over
to Cloud Shell here.
So I've got my environment
all up and running.
I want to show you
a couple of things.
So the first is the
container contract
that I mentioned-- listening
on a specific port.
So this is pretty easy to do in
most languages and frameworks.
For Elixir, this happens
to be how you specify
this in the cowboy config.
Tell it to pull it from
the system environment
variable called port.
By default, this is
typically hardcoded.
So you might find,
depending on your language
or your framework, it might
listen on 4000, by default,
4200, 8080, 8000.
There's lots of different
variants in there,
so make sure you
get the right one.
The second thing is, I'm going
to show you the Docker file.
So there's loads, and loads of
examples out on the internet
for different Docker files.
What I've done here
is I've actually
created a six-staged Docker
build, which, I know,
sounds scary.
I've done that to leverage
caching in the build system.
So if I build this
from scratch, it
takes about four minutes to
build using Google Cloud Build.
But with the caching, if
I just change one file,
I'm able to recycle and get a
new container within a minute,
then we can get that deployed
fairly quickly on Cloud Run.
So here I'm doing,
again, nothing funny.
I'm pulling from the
Elixir 1.8 Alpine
image, which is maintained
by the Elixir community.
Of course Alpine then
being a slimmed down image.
What this gives
me is it gives me
the entire build chain that
I need to build and release
an Elixir application.
Again, there's a couple
of different steps
here with different
layers, where
I'm copying specific
files, looking for hey,
if the mixed build file has
changed, execute this layer.
If it hasn't, used
the cache one.
Move on to the next thing.
It's compiling all
the static assets,
compiling my application.
And then what I'm doing is,
in the last stage there,
I'm pulling a vanilla
Alpine 39 image,
copying over just the
binary, just the Erlang
VM, my application, and
then a simple start command.
So I actually have
a very small image.
This is less than
40 megabytes when
pushed to GCR, which means that
it deploys and starts up very
quickly.
And then the bot code
itself, for those of you who
are interested and
want to dig in later,
I have a simple
configuration here.
This is a list of tuples
with strings to look for
and functions to dispatch to.
And then in the bot
here, this is the code
that we're going
to actually change.
So in the Create function,
create a meme right here.
So in the message that I get--
oh, that's create templates.
Let's see-- create meme.
In the message that
I get from Hangouts
Chat has some
additional information
about who sent the request.
So I'm just going to pull the
sender name from that JSON
that I get in and say,
created by sender name.
So it's simple code change.
I'm just going to--oh, I
don't have Mix installed here.
So what I'm going to do is I'm
going to actually send this
over to Google Cloud Build.
G Cloud Build, Submit, give it
a tag for where I want it to go.
We support tags
on GCR, so if you
want to tag something as
v1, or switch to a v2,
maybe switch between
them, we support that.
At deploy time, we resolve
the current value of that tag
to the image digests, so that
if we ever had to redeploy that
in the future-- which is a
feature that's coming soon--
we would pull the exact
same image and not
the new one from the tags.
So I'm going to go ahead
and hit Submit on that.
Like I said, this takes
about a minute or so.
So we're going to switch
back to the slides,
and we're going to
talk rather than let
you watch the build output,
because it's not very exciting.
STEREN GIANNINI:
Thank you, Mike.
MICHAEL HELMICK:
Thank you, Steren.
STEREN GIANNINI: So let's
recap what's happened here.
We had source code, and
we packaged all of this
into a container image.
To do so, the de-facto tool
that everybody has heard of
is Docker, the Docker command
line, Docker build -t,
Docker push.
This is something,
too, that you can
use to build containers
images locally, on your CI
system, whatever you want,
As Mike has used,
Google Cloud also offers
Build as a service if you
want, where you only pay
for when the Build is running.
And when nothing happens,
it's all managed for you.
So this is Cloud Build.
For Cloud Build, you
can do a Docker build.
This is what Mike has done, but
you can also do more complex,
multi-stage builds
with Cloud build.YAML.
Feel free to look at
the documentation.
It's quite powerful actually,
because Cloud Build at the end
can build containers that can
do much more, like deploying
or executing actions.
So we can use Cloud Build
for continuous delivery, too.
Personally, I recommend
two other tools
to build containers.
If you are Java
developers, I heard
that Jib is very, very good.
So Jib will allow you to, by
importing a Maven package,
build a container
for your Java app
without even having
Docker installed locally.
So then you use
it at one command,
and you have a container
from a Maven package
that you installed
from that XML.
Also, personally, I'm
a fan of buildpacks.
Buildpacks will help you go from
a source in a given language
to a container.
The recipe to transform
your source into a container
is contained inside
the buildpack.
And so at the end, you run one
command, which is a pack build.
And you will end up with
a container at the end,
without even having to worry
about writing the Docker file.
And as I said, I encourage
you, with containers,
to leverage this continuous
integration systems
and continuous delivery.
That means that you build
your container once,
then you run your test on it.
Then you deploy it to staging.
Then you deploy
it to production.
But it's always
the same container.
It's the one you've
built once and you tested
that goes into production.
It's not some source that
are rebuilt every time.
So we are very sure that it's
really the right thing that
goes to prod.
And so for this, as
I said, Cloud Build
can be a very easy
tool to do so,
but of course, Jenkins
and many other tools
are helping you do that.
Then once you have
your container image,
as we've seen in the first demo,
you can deploy it to Cloud Run.
So you can do it from
the user interface.
You can do it from
the command line,
gcloud beta run deploy
dash dash image.
And so here, you go from
your container image
in Google Cloud
Container Registry
to Cloud Run with one command.
On Cloud Run, you get an
endpoint to invoke it.
And all of this, if you
remember from the first demo,
happens very fast, in
just a few seconds.
I think, once it's
on Cloud Run--
MICHAEL HELMICK: Yeah,
once it's on Cloud Run,
we give you a URL.
Everything you deploy
will automatically
get a stable URL
for that service
under the run.app
domain, secured with SSL.
If that doesn't work for you,
we offer free custom domain
mapping.
So any domain you own, you
can bring your base domain
or a subdomain off
that base domain,
map it to an individual
Cloud Run service.
And with that, we give
you a free SSL certificate
that we will auto-renew
for you about a month
before it expires.
We give a little
bit of leeway there.
Free certificates
from Let's Encrypt.
We also offer Firebase
Hosting integration.
Firebase Hosting allows
you to add static content
through a CDM, or you can
do cached API requests.
So if you are serving something,
where the answer to the API
doesn't change very frequently,
doing a Firebase hosting
integration is potentially
a good solution for you
in that space.
So the container
built. I checked
while Steren was talking.
So let's switch back
over to the demo.
We're going to actually go
ahead and deploy this change.
So you can see here that it took
a minute and 42 seconds, which
is less than half of the
time for a complete build.
So that's good.
I encourage you to look at the
caching functionality of Google
Cloud Build.
And it gives me the output here.
So let's see.
So I'm going to go in.
I'm going to cheat.
I've got the command
already there.
So g cloud beta run deploy.
The name of the service,
dash dash image, the name
of the image, hit Deploy.
So I'm going to hit that.
While that's going, I'm
going to talk about a couple
of other things you can do
on the command line here.
You can specify the memory
for your containers.
So the default memory is
256 megabytes per instance.
You can scale that up to
2 gigabytes for instance,
depending on what
you need to do.
I've already specified
512 for this container,
but I don't need to specify
it every time I deploy.
We remember server-side
what your settings are.
Same thing with
environment variables.
There's a couple of
environment variables
that this particular
container uses.
I specified those the
first time that I deployed.
I don't need to
specify them again.
So we remember all
of that server-side.
OK, so this is done.
I'll show you where that's
persisted real quick.
So if I go back over
to the Cloud console,
go into the chatbot
service, I can
see the list of all of the
revisions that I've pushed.
So we preserve the
history for you there.
And I can see here that I have a
couple of environment variables
that were set.
I see the concurrency.
I have this little
tab called YAML,
so we're going to talk a
little bit about the API.
I'll show an example
on the slides later.
Give you a preview now.
You see at the top
there-- serving
dot Knative dot dev v1 alpha 1.
This is the Knative Serving API
completely represented for you
in a managed service.
OK, so to prove
that this worked,
we'll go back over
to the chat bot.
We'll create that
same meme again.
And this time, it should
say who created it.
There we go.
OK, so we clearly got
a cold start there,
which happens when
you deploy a new one,
but interactively
now much faster.
In summary there, we
built [INAUDIBLE] change.
We built an image.
We deployed it to Cloud Run.
That new version
was up and running
within 10 to 15 seconds.
So let's switch back to the
slides, talk a little bit more
about some of the stuff
that's going on there.
At a high level, I want to talk
a little bit about the resource
model that we used.
I mentioned, it's the
Knative Serving API.
The top level object
in there is service.
So you create a service.
Requests come into a service.
Every time you
change that service,
you get a new revision, so
revision 1, revision 2, so on
and so forth.
Only one revision is
serving at a time.
So if you dig under the hood
of the Knative service object,
there's a couple
that we call modes.
There's run latest
mode, which is currently
what Cloud Run supports.
There are also some other
modes, like release mode, that
lets you do a traffic split.
Those things are coming soon.
When requests come in for
the current latest revision,
we scale the number
of container instances
of that revision that are needed
to handle the incoming traffic.
And we scale that
both up and down,
and you're only billed
when you're actually
handling a user request.
In the Knative
resource model, there's
a couple of other objects.
There's route and configuration
and also the revision resource,
in particular.
We do expose all of
those Knative objects
in read-only mode.
So you can really dig in and
see exactly what's going on
with your declarative
config, but we
do require all changes right
now to go through the service
object.
I showed you the preview before,
but again, Knative Serving API.
If you go to GitHub.com
slash Knative
slash serving, you can see
the entire Knative Serving
project, all of the issues,
designs, what you've written,
things like that.
And then, again, under the hood,
you have the YAML file here.
So currently, we do
not support kubectl.
We cannot take requests
through that same declarative
interface.
That support is also
coming later this year.
But the same interface,
so the same config,
you can take from Cloud Run.
Move it over to
Cloud Run on GKE.
Get the same container up and
running in that environment.
Cloud Run is a regional service.
Each service lives in
a different region.
You can deploy the same
service to multiple regions,
if you like.
We do not currently offer
a global load balancing
over those regions.
And right now, we're
live in US central one,
but we have a bunch
more regions that
are going to be coming
online very, very soon.
It's not going to be a
long wait, I promise.
So Steren's going
to talk a little bit
about the invoker permissions
and private services.
STEREN GIANNINI: Yeah,
let's spend some time
on a very important
concept of Cloud Run.
So as Mike described,
requests are coming in,
and they are reaching
your service or not.
Because in front
of your service,
there is a notification
layer that you
use IAM to control
who has the permission
to invoke that service.
So for example, it can be
anybody with all users.
It can be a specific
user or even
a specific service account.
So this feature is key to
doing public or private
microservices.
And let's see a few use cases
how you can use that feature.
You will see, it's
quite powerful.
So the easiest one,
the most obvious one
is you have a Cloud Run service.
You want to expose it to
the internet to anybody.
In that case, there is no
authentication required
to invoke your service.
How you achieve that is by
giving all users the right
to invoke your service.
All right, this is
a public service.
Now, if, within
your architecture,
you have one microservice that
calls another microservice,
for example, your frontend
now invokes your backend,
while your backend is not
exposed to the internet.
So to be sure that
only the frontend can
call your backend
and not anybody
or not even your development
team on production,
well, this is how you can do it.
You can give the invoke
permission to the frontend
service account.
Because each Cloud Run service
is associated with a service
account.
And so then when your
frontend calls your backend,
it has to do it by
sending with the request
a special header to
authorize the request.
Once you do this, only the
frontend can call the backend.
So all of this is
leveraging IAM,
something you
probably know already
if you are using Google Cloud.
But that's not it.
If you want to do
asynchronous event processing,
I recommend you to use Pub/Sub
to create a topic, and then
a subscription.
And then here, what
you do is that you
give to the subscription an
identity with the service
account.
This is the thing
you see on the top.
And then your service, you only
allow that Pub/Sub identity
to invoke your service.
So once again, your service
is completely private,
and only Pub/Sub has the
ability to invoke it.
That's how you make asynchronous
processing super-secure.
So in that case, I
give the invoker role
to the Pub/Sub service account.
And by the way, when you
use Pub/Sub in Cloud Run,
the run dot app URLs are
already validated for you.
You don't need to
do a verification
step of ownership of that URL.
We already know its yours.
This is Pub/Sub.
One of my other
tools in my tool belt
is Cloud Tasks, which
as of maybe yesterday,
is now supporting HTTP targets.
So Cloud Tasks is a
queuing mechanism.
You can send tasks to
a queue, and the queue
will ensure that the tasks
are processed by pushing them
to a Cloud Run service or
to an App Engine service.
And in the case of a Cloud
Run service, it's the same.
You give the service
account of Cloud Tasks
the permission to
invoke your service.
It's like Pub/Sub.
One other very useful
tool that you should all
know about that exists in
GCP is Cloud Scheduler.
Cloud Scheduler is the most
simplest tool you can think of.
It's Cron as a service.
And here, it's the same.
You just say, I only execute
that service once a day.
Cloud Scheduler will
take care of that.
Once a day, it
will send a request
to your Cloud Run service.
And again, you can
leverage IAM to ensure
that only Cloud Scheduler is
able to invoke your service
and not exposing
it to the internet.
So same-- you give the invoker
role to the Cloud Scheduler
service account.
Let's see a demo of how
Cloud Run can actually scale.
MICHAEL HELMICK: Yeah, so
let's switch over to demo.
What it is, I'm going to show
a demo of a service going
from zero clients to
15,000 concurrent clients
over the course of 60 seconds.
Each of these is
hitting a worker job
that I wrote that
simulates a real workload,
so it burns some CPU.
It sleeps to simulate, network
I/O, burn some CPU again.
So I'm going to hit Run.
This particular worker is using
a concurrency setting of 80.
And when I get to
the next slide,
I'm going to tell you
exactly what that means.
So our test is up and
running, off to the races.
So the linear line
that's going up
is the number of clients
that are hitting the service.
The blue line is the latency.
So I would expect the
latency to be a little bit
variable, as we scale up the
number of container instances.
But then it should level out
as we get to a steady state.
So up to 6,000 clients.
They should be sending
about 2 QPS each.
So as we cross
8,000 clients here,
that means we're handling
about 16,000 QPS in 30 seconds
after starting at 0,
where 0, the service
was completely idle.
It's crossed 10,000,
so we're on the way.
Up again to 15,000 over
the course of 60 seconds.
We've successfully handled
over half a million requests.
Just crossed 600,000
successful requests.
There's a couple
of errors in there.
Sometimes we do see
some errors when
you send a whole bunch
of load really quickly
and have to scale up.
So we got 15,000 clients.
We successfully handled
over 800,000 requests.
Again, this scaled
up from nothing
to a whole bunch of
instances very, very quickly.
So let's switch
back to the slides.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you Can we switch
back to the slides please?
Talk a little bit about
the concurrency settings.
So we showed some stuff
with automatic scaling.
Let's talk about concurrency.
So in many serverless
applications
today, concurrency setting
is one or, we call,
single concurrency.
That means that any
instance is only
going to be handling
one request at a time.
So AWS Lambda and
Google Cloud Functions
both use this single
concurrency model.
What that means is that
you may have to start up
a whole bunch more instances.
You might experience a
lot more cold starts.
In Cloud Run, we let you
have multi-concurrency
into a single
container instance.
So we go up to 80.
You can specify, actually,
any number from 1 to 1,000,
because that's what Knative
allows you to specify.
But the limit is 80.
I'll be open with you here.
And what this allows you
to do is optimize resource
consumption.
So if you have a service that
makes lots of network calls,
there's no reason not
to put multiple requests
into that container at once--
avoid the cold start--
unless you do optimized cost.
You're only paying for the time
that your container is running.
So if you're able to bin pack
and get a lot of the shared
CPU in there, you can actually
end up with a lower cost
overall.
If you have a
CPU-bound workload,
if you are you using that CPU
at 100% for the entire duration
of the user request,
single concurrency
probably actually makes
more sense for you.
So there's a lot of variability
in what you actually need.
And you can set this to
any integer along the way.
So what I've done
is I've run a couple
of load tests with different
concurrency settings here.
So you can see here, with 400
clients sending three QPS--
three requests per second--
the number of instances I
needed on a single concurrency
was just over 500.
So it was about 540 or so.
And that was able to scale
up very quickly, as you
can see here.
As the traffic drops off, those
instances start to go away.
So again, you're only paying
for when it's actually
handling requests.
Run that same test with
a concurrency of 80,
I take out about 150 instances.
So I don't know exactly what
the cost was between those two
tests, but I know
this one was cheaper.
There's less CPU time,
less instances involved.
So this is truly a
pay-for-what-you-use
experience, rapid scale
up, rapid scale down.
Steren's going to
talk a little bit
about how you can actually
debug and run these things, too.
It's important things.
STEREN GIANNINI:
So out of the box,
as you would expect from
any serverless platform,
we give you visibility
into your services
by integrating with
Stackdriver monitoring.
You see all of your request
logs, application logs,
[INAUDIBLE] dev logs
into Stackdriver Logging.
And when you use Stackdriver
Logging, as you might know,
your exceptions are going
to be automatically captured
and grouped into error
groups into Stackdriver error
reporting.
All of this is out
of the box as soon
as you start using Cloud Run.
We are also partnering
with Datadog,
who are supporting Cloud Run
as a monitoring solution.
So as you've seen in Mike's
demo, Cloud Run scales--
scales up and scales down.
It's very important to know that
each of your Cloud Run services
will be automatically scaled
to as many container instances
as needed to handle
the incoming requests.
The concurrency is on each
of those container instance.
But the container
instance can go very high,
like you've seen in Mike's demo.
I think it went up to 500
when you had concurrency of 1.
But what does that
mean for your bills?
Well, what you pay is not the
number of scheduled instances.
What you pay for is
the exact CPU, memory,
and number of requests
that you are actually
using down to a granularity
of a 100 milliseconds.
So what that means is that the
auto-scaling is our problem.
You only pay when there
is a request coming
to your services.
So let's take an example.
Let's look at one
of those instances.
We can have many of them,
but let's look at one.
This instance will
consume CPU and memory.
But when are we charging you for
the CPU and memory depends on
if it is processing
requests or not.
So on the x-axis, it's the time.
But let's see.
A first request arrives
and is returned.
Another request arrives
This can happen,
because, as you know,
Cloud Run has
multiple concurrency.
So on Cloud Functions,
it's only one request
at a time in a given instance.
But on Cloud Run,
two requests can
come at the same time
on a given instance.
When that happens, what
we are charging you for
is the beginning of
the first request up
to the end of the last request.
Outside of this, you
are charged zero.
You don't pay for anything
outside of the processing
of the request.
You only pay for
CPU memory that you
use when your containers
are processing requests.
So from your perspective,
it's literally
scaled down to zero instantly.
From our perspective, we might
keep some things warm in case
more requests arrive.
But really, from the
perspective of your bill,
you stop paying as soon as
the requests are returned.
And how can we achieve
that magical scaling?
Mike is going to
tell you a bit more.
MICHAEL HELMICK:
There's lots of magic.
I'm going to talk
about one piece.
We're talking about gVisor.
gVisor is the container
sandbox runtime
that we use on Cloud Run.
It's an open source
project run by Google.
gVisor.dev is where you can
get a lot more information
about that.
It provides a secure
container isolation boundary.
So we're able to start these
instances extremely fast,
tear them down.
It's very cheap to do.
One thing about gVisor--
not all sys calls
are implemented.
So you might run into some
unimplemented sys call
warnings, which we put
into your Stackdriver logs.
So if you find that
your application is not
working the way
you expect, I would
encourage you to go look there.
A couple of things about that--
not all unimplemented sys calls
are a symptom that something
is not working correctly.
So I see set SOC ops is
one that is unimplemented
for some of the arities
of that function call.
And usually, that's
a red herring.
It's not actually a problem.
If you do find that
unimplemented calls
are actually causing a
problem for you application.
We encourage you
to contact support.
And we can work with
you to try to figure out
exactly what's going on there.
STEREN GIANNINI: You might
hit some, what we call,
limits of the fully-managed
version of Cloud Run.
For example, today, you cannot
pick more than 1 vCPU or more
than 2 gigabytes of RAM.
You do not have access
to a GPU on Cloud Run.
We do not yet allow you
to connect to Cloud SQL
or to connect to your VPC.
But that's coming very soon.
And as Mike mentioned,
we do not yet
integrate with Google
Cloud Load Balancer.
But you know what?
We have another version of Cloud
Run, which is Cloud Run on GKE.
So if you feel limited by
those restrictions, well,
you can benefit from the
exact same Cloud Run developer
experience, auto-scaling,
and automatic endpoints,
but within your own GKE cluster.
That is called Cloud Run on GKE.
And the two have been designed
to expose the exact same API,
which is the Knative API.
It's super-easy to switch
between one or the other
if you can change
your mind later.
And really, it has
been designed so
that, if you feel
limited by one,
you can go to the other, in
your own cluster this time.
So next, I would like
to invite on stage
one of or alpha testers,
who have been working
with us for months on Cloud
Run, Antoine and Sebastian
from Veolia.
ANTOINE CASTEX: Thank you.
Hi, everybody.
[APPLAUSE]
Before telling you more
details about the use case
we have on Cloud Run,
obviously, it's normal for me
that I need to introduce
to you what is Veolia.
Because it's very
important for you
to understand how the
business of Veolia
is very into the
solution like that.
So we work for Veolia.
We are 170,000 people working
in more than 50 countries
around the world.
We are a French company,
but we are known worldwide.
We have a different use
case, a different solution.
And on this particular
use case, you
will clearly understand what is
very linked to the job we have.
And what the jobs we have?
Three different jobs.
The first one is the water.
By water, I mean, collecting
water, providing solution
for water, and recycling water.
The second one is the waste.
Waste management-- that mean
we will secure your waste
for millions of tons every year.
The last one is the
energy solution.
We provide an energy solution
for the industry for a lot
of cities around the world.
To be just more precisely,
the cats on the slide
is just for the fun.
We don't recycle the cats.
Don't be afraid.
But before telling you more
about the use case we have,
it is very important for me to
introduce to you what the cloud
strategy that we have.
You will understand that.
We have five
principle PR on that.
The first one is no ops.
When I say no ops, I say,
when we have a new use case,
when we are transforming an
existing application, first
of all, we every time think
about using microservices.
Microservices mean using
solution, like Cloud Run.
And thank you, Steren.
Thank you, Mike.
But why?
This is just because
an application is not
fixed at the time.
Your application will
evolve in the time--
maybe tomorrow, maybe next
week, maybe next month.
And you need to be agile
on the developments.
The second point that will
link you to the first one
is the serverless.
We love App Engine.
We love Cloud Function.
And now, we love Cloud Run.
And that is very important,
not only because of your money,
because as Steren said, you
only pay for what you use.
But also because-- now, you know
that Veolia is an environmental
company--
we need to take care about the
consumption of the material
and the solution we use.
We only need to use a
solution when we need.
And as Steren say, on the
very nice billing models,
you are only charged of
the solution you need.
When the service is not running,
you not pay for anything.
So that means, for Veolia, we
are not using server of Google
when we don't need that.
That is the link between the
environmental impact of Veolia
and the environment
impact of Google.
Of course, we don't
want any data center,
because, as you probably know,
Google is doing that very well.
We are not an IT company.
That's not our jobs.
The first one is
secure by design.
You have seen a lot of different
layers of the solution that
promise you to be secure when
you develop an application
and you push the
code on Cloud Run.
That's why we love that.
And the last one is
that's why we are here.
We love using Google
Cloud and just
another one, a very
small company [INAUDIBLE]
that I don't have to mention.
Sebastien.
SEBASTIEN MORAND:
Thank you, Antoine.
So I am going to present
to you our use case.
In our use case, Veolia is
managing a water treatment
plant and [INAUDIBLE]
a lot of data.
And data can be sensitive or
subject to local regulation.
So we see for them with a
specific local algorithm,
where the private key is
the only store on site.
Then the date is ready
to go on Google Cloud.
So on Google Cloud, we have
two layers of security.
The first one is a native
Google Cloud Security layer,
and the second one is
the encryption on site.
On Cloud, we are
going to make a lot
of processing to make some
predictions for the local site.
During the water
process, if someone
tries to read the data,
even the local IT team
managing the Google
Cloud Workload,
you won't be able to read
the data, nor the data,
nor the result. Because
it's [? ciphered ?]
before the processing,
during the processing,
and after the processing.
Then the data is sent back to
the local site, and the client
can [INAUDIBLE] the
data with a private key
and get the insight of the data.
So how to do that?
To do that, we need first a
specific kind of algorithm
called homomorphic algorithm.
This kind of algorithm are
made from several trees
from tens to
hundreds and provided
by the CITECH Institute,
which is actually
the Atomic Energy Commission
Research Technology
center in France.
So this is kind of
algorithm, first,
we have to dispatch
the tree calculation
with the first entry point
in our Cloud Run instance.
Because actually,
the CITECH Institute
provides only binaries,
and these binaries
have been linked
into a Docker image.
So when we publish the
message for each tree,
we are going to trigger at
the same time all the tree
calculations.
And the result will be store
in a Cloud Firestore database.
When all the trees
have been calculated,
we calculate the
final step, which
is called a median calculation,
to have the final result
of the prediction.
And the results will be
sent back to the client.
During the whole process,
as I said before,
the data is
[? ciphered ?] completely.
So to implement the
use case, Cloud Run
bring us a lot of benefits.
The first one, of course,
as we have a Docker image
with binaries, we
could plug as a service
these Docker images
without any effort.
The automatic scaling,
because we have
a lot of trees to calculate--
sometimes several hundreds--
they can last a few minutes.
So calculating them
at the same time
is really something required
to have a quick answer
of the prediction.
Multi-route support
because we need
to dispatch the tree calculation
and the media calculation
as the same Docker image.
So through the multi-route,
we have only one deployment
to maintain.
Fast deployment is also
a mandatory feature,
because when we want to make
an upgrade on the algorithm,
we need to deploy quickly to
[? answer ?] the new feature
we want to improve.
And of course, the
last and not the least,
we save money, because
we only pay for what
we use during the processing.
Thank you.
STEREN GIANNINI: Thanks
to you for helping us
during this alpha and
beta of Cloud Run.
[APPLAUSE]
Your feedback was really
valuable during that phase,
and that's why we are very proud
to have you with us on stage
today.
OK, so as Sebastien
and Antoine mentioned,
Google Cloud has a few other
serverless compute options.
So I would like to spend
one minute helping you
how to pick one option.
It mostly depends on
the level of abstraction
you want to position
yourself at.
If you want to think in terms
of very simple function that are
source based, that can be
triggered via HTTP but also
by event triggers-- by
binding your function to some
resources--
then Cloud Functions is really
the perfect fit for that.
It's GA.
We announced many new
languages for Cloud Functions
yesterday, many new
features coming.
Really, serverless functions,
this is Cloud Functions.
For use cases that are more
web apps or web backends,
well, you also want to think
in terms of source code
and not have to deal
with the container.
Then App Engine would be the
best fit to run your serverless
applications.
So like Cloud Run, App Engine
scales up and down on demand
and takes your
source code as input.
We announced new
languages for App Engine's
standard environment recently.
And for anything else,
actually, that you
want to run on a
serverless environment that
is able to take as an
input an HTTP request,
Cloud Run will be the
best fit for that.
It is taking your
container image as an input
and can be triggered
[? via HTTP, ?] but also,
asynchronously using
Pub/Sub and Cloud Tasks.
So Cloud Run, to recap,
containers to production
in seconds.
The benefit of
containers are multiple.
You can put any
language, any binary
and package this into
a container and deploy.
It's very fast.
So as you see, serverless is
not only for functions anymore.
It takes a container and
runs it in a serverless way.
And yes, Cloud Run is
natively serverless.
As we demonstrated to you,
it scales up and down.
You only pay for the exact usage
of your Cloud Run instances.
And I haven't seen
any server to manage,
so there is no infrastructure
management with Cloud Run.
And lastly, we haven't put
so much emphasis on this,
but Cloud Run gives you one
experience where you want it.
So what we've talked
today is mostly
about the fully-managed
version of Cloud Run.
But I also mentioned
Cloud Run on GKE,
which gives you
the same developer
experience, but this time,
inside your GKE cluster.
And as Mike mention,
all of this actually
exposes the Knative Serving API.
So thanks to that API
and runtime contract,
you can actually run
Cloud Run workloads
anywhere on Kubernetes where
you can install Knative.
So that removes the vendor
[? lock-in ?] that you might be
worried about.
So these are the three
pillars of Cloud One--
bringing serverless
agility to containers.
If you want to learn more,
I have a few sessions
to recommend.
One of them is an intro on
what's new in serverless.
Another one is an overview of
both Cloud Run and Cloud Run
on GKE.
And another one is a deep
dive similar to this one,
except that a deep dive
on Cloud Run on GKE.
If you want to ask us questions,
if you want to try the demo,
all of this is on GitHub.
And we are available
on Twitter, and you
can follow us on GitHub, too.
And lastly, I think,
Mike and I really
want to thank you for
attending this session.
We really want to
thank our alpha testers
for providing such
large amount of feedback
and helping us shape
Cloud Run for it
to be ready today for you.
We really want to thanks
our engineering teams, who
have put so much effort into
Cloud Run and Cloud Run on GKE.
And really, now, your next
step is definitely get started.
Give it a try.
Cloud.google.com/run.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]